- So I'm gonna walk around
the streets of Hollywood
and ask people if they
want to eat a raw onion.
What do you guys think about onions?
- I love onions.
- Pretty good.
- I like onions, Jake hates onions.
- I love em, use em all the time.
Red, organic, quite sweet, great.
- They make me cry.
- I like em grilled.
- They got layers.
- They're really good on cheeseburgers.
- I think onions are okay.
Sautéed I don't like em raw.
- Do you like onions raw?
- Actually yes.
- Sometimes.
- Uh, no.
- Not at all?
- No.
Not at all.
- Yeah.
- No.
- They make you cry
when you cut em.
- No.
- Absolutely. (laughing)
- Do you want to eat a raw onion?
- For how much?
- Nothin.
All I can offer you is the onion.
- For free?
I'm not that high.
- You can take an extra onion with you.
- I would consider it.
If I was hungry enough, I
definitely would do that.
- Would you consider it right now?
- Hmm, no.
Probably not right now.
- Would you eat an entire raw onion?
- No.
- Too much.
- No, you sure?
- It's too much.
- Are you gonna do that for this video?
- No.
- Okay.
- Would you?
- I wouldn't.
- I probably, I might.
- Would you consider eating
the entire raw onion on camera?
- Yes I would.
- Sure, why not.
- Okay.
Here we go.
(laughing)
- You have one in your backpack?
- I sure do.
- I won't eat it, but I'll hold the peel.
- Here's your sweet onion.
Have at it.
(crunching)
- He just walks around with
an onion in his backpack.
(crunching)
- This is pretty good.
- That's a decent bite of an onion.
Don't breathe on me.
- Do you want anymore of this?
(crunching)
- It's delicious dude.
- Regretting your decision?
- No.
- I'm regretting her decision. (laughing)
- This is actually kinda, kinda good.
(laughing)
- What's that onion doing to you?
- That's it?
- That's it.
- Are you crying?
She's tearing up already.
- So beautiful.
That is all I can do.
I am very glad that I stepped
out of my comfort zone today.
- Could you ever see
yourself doin that again?
- No.
Well I am.
I don't know.
Nobody, nobody ever asked
me to eat an onion before.
- Was it better or
worse than you expected?
- It was actually a little bit better.
Because I was expecting
to maybe only take,
be able to take one or two
bites before I wimped out,
but I am very proud of myself,
I ate half an onion today.
- Well folks, we did it.
We got people to take
a bite of a raw onion.
(crunching)
- The real news is too ridiculous.
You make people eat
onions, what are you doin?